DON’T LOOK BACK:
On August 10, 2015, Larry Page and Sergey
Brin made Sundar Pichai the CEO of Google. At
first glance, it seemed like the duo just wanted
to play a more hands off role at the company.
While Sundar handled all of the day to day
nuances of running Google, Larry and Sergey could
focus on the long term future of the company. But,
just 4 years later in December of 2019, Larry
and Sergey would make Sundar the CEO of Alphabet
itself and they would more or less fall of the
grid completely. They rarely make any public
appearances and they’re notorious for skipping
meetings. This is quite out of the blue given
that most founders tend to play a significant role
in their companies until the day they die. I mean
just look at Warren Buffett or Churlie Munger.
Larry and Sergey, however, have truly left the
company and the spotlight despite still having 51%
control of the company. This is a pretty bold move
given that their entire fortunes depend on the
performance of Google. If you ask them directly,
they’ll tell you that it was time to assume the
role of proud parents - offering advice and love,
but not daily nagging. But, if you take a closer
look, you’ll see that there’s more to this than
they let on. It’s not that Larry and Sergey
don’t have visions for Google or that they
don’t want to lead the company. Rather, they’ve
found that everytime they try to take the reigns
of the company, shareholders aren’t particularly
happy. And this wasn’t a one or two time event,
it was a consistent theme throughout their
entire time at Google. It seems that eventually,
they came to accept that the goals of Google
and their own goals simply did not align. And
instead of trying to resist, they did
the classy thing and truly retired. So,
here’s the truth behind why Google’s founders
really ditched Google and never looked back.
FIRST TRY AS CEO:
While Larry and Sergey didn’t leave till recent
years, their unorthodox leadership style was
evident from day one. Likely one of the best
examples of this was Larry’s workplace rulebook
which consisted of five rules. Rule #1 was Don’t
delegate: do everything you can yourself to make
things go faster. This is quite ironic given that
you could argue that Larry himself is breaking
this rule today. Putting that aside though,
effective delegation within any business is
extremely important, but Larry was actively
encouraging employees to specifically avoid
delegation. Moving onto rule #2, we have don't
get in the way if you're not adding value. Let
the people actually doing the work talk to each
other while you go do something else. Rule #2
was Don’t be a bureaucrat. Rule #4 was Ideas are
more important than age. Just because someone is
junior doesn't mean they don't deserve respect
and cooperation. And finally, Rule #5 was The
worst thing you can do is stop someone from doing
something by saying, “No. Period.” If you say no,
you have to help them find a better way to get
it done. While many of these rules do make sense,
Larry’s motivation for these rules weren’t exactly
pure. You see, Larry wasn’t trying to create a
harmony between managers and engineers. Rather,
he was trying to completely eliminate managers
altogether because he didn’t like the idea of
non-engineers supervising engineers. He felt that
this supervision was not only unnecessary but also
an impediment. Larry was extremely confident in
the quality of his engineering hires, and he felt
that there was no reason for them to be babysit,
hence the rule book. Larry was hoping that the
rule book would keep managers out of the hairs
of engineers. But, with time, he came to realize
that this wasn’t the case and he became more and
more irritated. One of the factors that pushed him
over the edge was the fact that he wasn’t seeing
any progress on his book searching idea. Larry
wanted Google to be able to scan all the books
in the world and then make them searchable
online, you’re probably familiar with this
feature today. But, this wasn’t going well, and I
don’t think you’d be surprised that he blamed the
project managers. Instead of holding a meeting
with the managers like a reasonable CEO though,
he would hold a townhall style meeting with all
the managers and engineers in July of 2001. He
would go on to insult all of the managers in
front of everyone before firing them all. To
Larry’s surprise though, this didn’t get anyone
fired except himself. As you guess, the project
managers were not happy with the choice for
obvious reasons. But, it wasn’t just the project
managers that were unhappy either. Many engineers
weren’t convinced by this move either. One
engineer even yelled at Larry declaring that
what he was doing was completely ridiculous
and totally unprofessional. Google’s
human resources boss, Stacy Sullivan,
would escalate this issue to the chairman of
Google, Eric Schmidt, who had been placed there
by Google’s investors. Eric would of course
side with the managers and this resulted in
most of the managers being reinstated and Larry
being demoted from being CEO. Eric would take on
this role so that he could supervise Larry and
Sergey. Let’s just say Larry was very unhappy.
BABYSITTING:
Fortunately for Eric, he didn’t have to do too
much babysitting over the next several years
because Larry and Sergey didn’t poke around too
much when it came to the operations of Google.
Instead, they focused acquisitions which they
knocked out of the park. First, they had the
Android acquisition in 2005 which cost Google $50
million. Larry actually completed this acquisition
without even telling Eric, but he didn’t mind.
From Eric’s perspective, Google was already a
$100 billion company and if a mere $50 million
could keep Larry occupied and prevent him from
making any more rash decisions at Google, that
was a major win, and that’s exactly what happened.
Over the next few years, Larry and Sergey would
be enthralled with making a bunch acquisitions.
And to their credit, many of their acquisitions
proved to be extremely successful like YouTube.
Aside from acquisitions, these two were also super
busy with what they like to call the moonshot
factory. Likely the two most famous inventions
out of this factory are of course the Google
self driving car and Google Glass. Pretty soon,
Eric began to feel that he could trust these two
once again. Not only were they making phenomenal
acquisitions and ground breaking innovations,
but they weren’t doing anything that was too
questionable either. They weren’t insulting
employees infront of each other nor were they
firing every manager in the company. It seemed
like the duo had matured as business leaders,
and shareholders very much agreed. So, in 2011,
when Eric stepped down as CEO, he would pass on
the title to Larry. But, it didn’t take long for
everyone to realize that nothing had changed for
Larry or Sergey. They had simply found an outlook
for their unorthodox ideas with acquisitions
and the moonshot factory. But, now that Larry
was back to running Google proper, many of the
same issues started to resurface once again.
SECOND TRY AS CEO:
A common theme for
Larry seems to be that he simply doesn’t like
oversight in general. Originally, he didn’t like
managers overseeing engineers, but that was before
Google went public. Now that Google was public,
one of his largest concerns was investor oversight
of Google, but he wasn’t gonna immediately try to
tackle that issue. The reason that he got screwed
a decade ago was because the employees weren’t on
his side. So, this time he was going to make
sure that investors were on his side before he
tried anything too radical. And this started
with giving investors what they wanted most:
sustainable growth. Larry started off
by slashing Google’s products, features,
and services. Apparently, he reduced these by
70 within just 2 years of taking over. He also
placed an emphasis on design and simplicity trying
to emulate some of Apple’s success within that
realm. And finally, Larry also implemented
a new constraint for acquisitions called
the toothbrush test. Instead of looking at the
profitability or financials of a given company,
Google evaluated these companies based
on their usefulness alone. If a company
offers something that people will use once or
twice per day and it makes their life better,
the company is a winner. If it doesn’t do that,
however, Larry wouldn’t buy the company even if
they have tremendous financials. While this
was defintely on the side of unorthodox,
it worked. Google’s revenue was growing, their
profits were growing, and most importantly,
their stock price was growing. Investors were
starting to trust Larry, but it didn’t take
very long for him to take things too far once
again with Google Island. If you haven’t heard
about Google Island, it was essentially Larry’s
idea to take Google off the grid not necessarily
physically but metaphorically. He wanted Google
to have freedom from not only investors but also
government regulation. One of his proposed ideas
was that laws older than 50 years wouldn’t apply
to tech companies. TechCrunch put it as Larry
wanting the Earth to have a mad scientist island
that was run by Google. While this may sound
cool in theory, it was also super unrealistic.
Google Island would not only free Google from
some of the barriers of innovation but it would
also free them from accountability altogether. If
neither the government nor investors could keep
Google accountable, who would? Obviously, Larry
believed that he could keep Google accountable,
but this was more of a pipe dream than anything.
After pitching this idea, dozens of publications
would ruthlessly bag on Larry claiming that he was
completely out of touch from reality. And almost
all of them posed the same question: is this the
type of guy you wanted to be in charge of Google?
A REALIZATION:
No one would fire Larry from his position the
second time around, but Larry himself had come
to a realization: Google would never be what he
wanted it to be. This isn’t to say that Google
wouldn’t be successful or that it wouldn’t make a
boatload of money because it’s done both of those.
But, what this did mean though is that Google
would never become a groundbreaking research
institution which is what Larry and Sergey
wanted from day 1. Larry and Sergey were never
your traditional tech founders. They weren’t your
classic college dropouts who wanted to change the
world and became megarich. They were actually PhD
students who founded Google as a research project.
And while they were all for the financial side of
Google, they didn’t want for Google to lose its
identity as a research institution either.
But with time, it was clear that investors
didn’t really care about this unless it could
directly be linked to profits. At the same time,
both Larry and Sergey were both facing significant
personal challenges as well. Larry had been
struggling with vocal chord paralysis for much of
his adult life and things were only getting worse
in the early 2010s. This made it especially
difficult for Larry to engage in interviews,
earnings calls, and other PR events which are
extremely important for any public company CEO.
This would make Larry infamous for being MIA.
Meanwhile, Sergey had gotten caught up in an
affair which not only ruined his public reputation
but also his relationship with Larry who has
refused to speak to him since. Given that Larry
and Sergey have 51% voting power at Google,
they could technically take Google in whatever
direction they want. But, given that they only
own about 14% of the company together, I think it
was pretty clear to them that abusing their voting
power would be a pretty douchy thing to do to the
other 86% of shareholders. So, they would decide
to do the classy thing and give shareholders
what they wanted. They gave the shareholders
a CEO that could grow Google into a trillion
dollar company: Sundar Pichai. In the meantime,
Larry and Sergey have ventured off into
what they’ve always wanted to do. Research
exciting ideas like flying cars and anti aging and
hopefully bring them to fruition. And that’s why
Google’s founders really left Google. Do you think
Google would be better under Larry and Sergey’s
leadership? Comment that down below. Also, drop a
like if you hope that Google doesn't forget their
slogan: Don’t be Evil. And of course, consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.